hello everyone
welcome to another episode of science
and technology q a
for kids and others and i see we have a
whole bunch of questions that are
left over from last week so let me take
a look a few of these
there's a question from slayer here
about what happens if you fall into the
ocean from a great height from what i've
read it's like hitting concrete can you
explain the science behind this
well let's see there are many parts of
that so one question is
if you drop something from
the top of a tall building from an
airplane something like that
how fast does it fall so there are two
pieces to this
one is how fast would it fall if there
wasn't any air
another question another part of that is
how fast does it fall given that there's
air on earth
so if you were to so let's start off
with the question of
how fast do things fall ignoring the
fact that there's
air assume you were dropping something
on the moon where there's no
there's no atmosphere where it's just a
vacuum how fast do things fall
well so the answer is that gravity
on that there's a the the basic
thing that happens is when you're
dealing with something like a planet a
big object that has a lot of mass
it has it produces a gravitational field
it it produces a a pull of gravity
that will pull any object that has mass
towards it
and there's at the surface of the earth
there's this
idea of the acceleration due to gravity
which is about 9.81
meters per second per second so what
does it mean the acceleration due to
gravity
so gravity is a force that is pulling
objects that have mass
towards the earth towards specifically
towards the center of the earth
and the um when you there's newton's
second law
says force is equal to mass times
acceleration so you can turn that around
and say acceleration is force over mass
but you can say that that the um uh
well this is a guy got a little bit
complicated here but but
um the force due to gravity is
proportional to mass and so those
masses cancel out and so the result is
that when
something is falling towards something
like the earth
what the effect of gravity is just to
accelerate
the motion of the the of the object so
what does that mean
so something is traveling at a certain
speed
acceleration is the rate of change of
that speed with time
and so what this is saying is that
when something falls near the earth
it is is every second
it is going 9.8 meters per second faster
than it was in the previous second
it's about 32 feet per second per second
i think
um the uh so in other words what that
means is at
some uh at this second the thing might
be going
let's say at zero miles an hour the next
second
it's going at some number of miles an
hour
uh some larger number of miles an hour
the next second it's going
at twice that number of miles an hour
and so on so
at every moment it is increasing its
speed
so that's what the effect of gravity uh
does that and
that's true of any any large object like
the earth
in a first approximation things just
fall at a certain constant acceleration
towards the earth
same on the moon uh same same on other
planets
the the acceleration due to gravity is
different
on the earth than it is on the moon
because a couple of things contribute
that the total mass of the earth
compared to the size of the earth
determines the acceleration due to
gravity at the surface of the earth
and so for example on the moon the
acceleration due to gravity is about
one-sixth
the acceleration due to gravity on the
earth so the rate that things accelerate
when they're falling on the moon
is one-sixth the rate they accelerate
when they're falling towards the earth
now on the surface of the earth the
acceleration due to gravity is more or
less this constant 9.8 meters per second
per second
uh in most places on the earth there's a
slight variation
because for example uh when
the for example if there's a big
mountain
if you if there's a question if you if
you drop something on the
near the side of a mountain the mountain
itself has a bunch of mass
and so there will be a tendency for
gravity
the mountain will produce gravity and so
the object instead of falling sort of
straight down towards the center of the
earth
it will be deflected to fall slightly
towards the mountain
because there's mass in the mountain
that is like a miniature earth
in a sense that's that's pulling the
thing towards it so there is some
variation of this 9.8 meters per second
per second
uh in different places on the surface of
the earth that has to do with
things like that um and it isn't even
always necessarily pointed precisely
towards the center of the earth
if you go away from the earth eventually
if you go far enough away from the earth
there's no pull of gravity there's no
acceleration due to gravity from the
earth
because the earth is the the amount of
the amount of gravitational force goes
down like the
one over the square of the distance
between you and the object that's
pulling on you
and so eventually when you get far
enough away from the earth the earth has
no effect
just like when on the surface of the
earth here if we ask
how much effect does the gravity of the
planet mars have on us the answer is
almost none so uh that 9.8 meters per
second per second
as you go into space for example
that that number will gradually decrease
so that the the amount of acceleration
due to gravity
will decrease as you move further away
from the earth okay so first point is
if you drop something towards the moon
it will simply accelerate as a result of
the gravity of the moon
and in a first approximation if you drop
something from
if you're really really a long way away
from the moon um
really like you know the distance the
way that mars is from
from from the moon then nothing's gonna
fall towards the moon
um but if you're if you're reasonably
close to the moon things will fall
towards the moon
they'll fall initially at an
acceleration it's a little bit lower
than the acceleration on the surface of
the moon
but pretty soon they'll be falling at
acceleration that's that's close to the
acceleration on the surface of the moon
and the moon which doesn't have any
atmosphere they'll just
accelerate according to that rule and
they'll just go faster and faster and
faster
and if the um uh and so it's a little
tricky you can
you can work out uh you kind of reverse
the problem and you could say if you
were shooting a rocket
from the earth how fast does the rocket
have to go
in order to fully escape the earth's
gravity the escape velocity of the earth
that's 25 000 miles an hour for the
earth
and that actually tells you if you were
to drop something from very far away
from the earth and let it accelerate due
to the acceleration
due to gravity as it as it approaches
the earth when it gets towards the the
surface of the earth it will be
accelerating at 9.8 meters per second
per second
when it's further away from the earth it
will be accelerating less rapidly
if you do the calculus thing of
integrating
that acceleration you can work out what
the velocity that the thing would have
when it gets to
the surface of the earth and the answer
is 25 000 miles per hour
so in other words if you dropped
something from far enough away from the
earth
and the earth didn't have an atmosphere
and you let the thing accelerate
towards the surface of the earth it will
be going at 25 000 miles an hour when it
hits the earth
and that's uh you can work that out for
other things for the sun for example
it's around
100 000 miles an hour um and so on
so uh that that's so assuming there was
no atmosphere
that's how fast things will be going
that's really fast
the um to give you a sense of scale you
know the speed of sound is around
600 700 miles an hour um depending on
exactly
what where in the atmosphere you are and
so on um so that's many times the speed
of sound
um the speed of uh oh what are some fast
things
um the fastest uh
the typical you know commercial
airplanes
fly at about maybe point eight times
eighty percent of the speed of sound
um the uh something like you know a
a bullet shot out uh goes at maybe
twice the speed of sound so 25 000 miles
an hour
is uh fully what is it it's about um
uh well that would be mark that that's
the sort of
that's unit of speed of sound that's
that's like um
well actually it's a that would be like
mark
30 or mark 40 or something that's
extremely fast
in terms of just sort of things
and and most things if
if you uh were to um
uh crash into the earth at that speed
not much would be left most things would
vaporize at that
speed okay so i'll tell you a little bit
of a story here
a couple of years ago uh
a friend of mine who has a slightly
peculiar activity
of trying to get uh sort of
objects that are kind of representative
of our
civilization deposited around the solar
system
managed to make an arrangement with an
israeli group
that was sending a spacecraft to the
moon a thing called the bereshit lander
um this spacecraft he got this little
quartz
disc that he got um uh placed on the
spacecraft it has
um a bunch of uh micro dot
versions of um lots of interesting works
of
of human literature and so on including
even some things i've written
um and it's kind of a cool thing to sort
of deposit that on the moon
as a as a backup of the backup of the
backup
of where you can put kind of the works
of our civilization
not clear who's ever going to look at it
but it's a it's a fun concept at least
to have that thing be on the moon
okay so the bad news was this lander as
it approached the moon
something went wrong and the lander
crashed into the moon
at i think about 2 000 miles an hour i
think it crashed into the moon
at close to the escape velocity of the
moon so that would be
uh let's see can i do my math properly
here
um well that would be a little bit
faster than that so
so um uh i think it was around 2000
miles an hour
that it crashed into the surface of the
moon and so the question was
when an object crashes into the surface
of the moon at two thousand miles an
hour
what happens and um uh
another friend of mine i who happened to
uh have a rocket company for a number of
years
i i asked them about this because they
had rockets that unfortunately failed
and they described the the process as
you know
imagine you take the main gun on a
battleship which has a big great big
shell
that it fires and you fire that gun into
a piece of concrete
that was his analogy for what would
happen if you
had the spacecraft hit the moon at 2000
miles an hour
and it's like there's not much left but
it turned out
that things were luckier than that
because it turned out this spacecraft
it had failed to fire its rocket engine
at the right time
and so it had it had failed to basically
come out of orbit properly so when
you're in orbit around
something like the moon you're going
around rapidly around
sort of and and parallel to the surface
of the moon you're
you're you're sort of uh you know you're
in orbit so you're going around the moon
but then when you if you if you want to
sort of land on the moon what you have
to do is kind of stop
the speed that you're going around in
the orbit and just go
to be kind of straight down towards the
moon sort of falling towards the moon
and hopefully firing your rocket engines
to stop you before you hit the surface
of the moon at high speed as we've been
just describing so this particular
spacecraft failed to de-orbit properly
and so it was still going sort of in
sort of parallel to the surface of the
moon as well as falling towards the moon
and so what happened is it actually hit
the surface of the moon
not straight down sort of splat
um but it hit it at an angle and in fact
it was at
like a five percent incline so it was it
was mostly going
most of that 2000 miles an hour was
going
uh parallel to the surface of the moon
it was kind of sliding relative to the
surface of the moon
not going splat straight down into the
moon so the question was then what
happens to a spacecraft
that hits the moon at that kind of angle
um as it's um uh uh
and the answer i i found a person who's
sort of a world expert on cratering
who said well actually the thing will
not just go splat into the surface of
the moon instead it will make a little
crater where it first
impacts and then it will bounce and
slide along the surface of the moon
so it will kind of be a thing where uh
on you can work out you know how long
will it take something
that's just you know sliding along a uh
uh you know something uh some i don't
know a beach or something sliding along
the sand
how long will it take a thing that's
that's started at 100 miles an hour
to stop when it's sliding along the sand
you can kind of work that out
and uh i had in fact done a little
calculation of that for this spacecraft
on the moon
assuming that it didn't run into a big
boulder and just sort of
crash into the boulder and i had worked
out that it would be
several miles that it would slide on the
surface of the moon much
because it was going very fast and also
there's less gravity on the moon
to make the friction higher so i was
kind of surprised by that result and
didn't really believe it
but the cratering expert told me that's
actually correct that the thing would
actually slide for like a mile or
something before coming to rest
so okay so then the question is what
actually happened to this thing
and the lunar reconnaissance orbiter
which takes high-resolution photographs
of the moon
uh had gone over the landing site and in
fact
you could compare the picture before the
spacecraft
uh impacted the moon and the picture
after
and you could see that yes there was in
fact
very satisfyingly there was this big
sort of streak
outwards that that from the from the
actual expected landing site there was a
kind of streak going in a certain
direction
and we worked out based on the the last
picture the spacecraft had taken
before it before it crashed we could
tell from that picture it had certain
craters in the picture
so we could tell where that picture was
taken and then we could figure out
by sort of joining the the vector from
where that picture was taken to the to
the crash site
we could tell what direction it was
going we could tell the ray that one
could see on the surface of the moon
from lunar reconnaissance orbiter
was in fact going in the correct
direction for the sliding of the
spacecraft
so it was undoubtedly doing exactly what
the cratering expert had said
and it was the spacecraft having sort of
bounced out of its initial crater
and then sliding over the surface of the
moon and quite possibly my friend's
quartz disc
is still intact on the surface of the
moon i will say that that my friend um
also sent some other rather more
questionable kinds of things to the
surface of the moon
um including some things called
tardigrades which are
a type of otherwise known as water bears
they're a type of critter
that survives very well in very adverse
circumstances including vacuums and
and very cold and so on and it wasn't
the smartest idea
to send some kind of living organism to
the surface of the moon probably
um it's uh it's something where you know
people come back in a long time and they
find oh wow
there's these critters living on the
surface of the moon well actually they
were sent there in the year 2020
by this person who didn't use the best
possible judgment about
what to put on a spacecraft going to the
moon um but in any case
uh that's that's sort of a a different
topic
okay so that's the story of what happens
when things are dropped
without an atmosphere when things just
go
fall according to the laws of gravity
and so on um
they end up uh if they're dropped from a
very great height they'll end up
crashing into the surface of the planet
or moon or whatever
at the escape velocity of that body
which is um
uh in the case of the earth 25 000 miles
per hour
okay but there's a big footnote to that
whole thing which is well the earth
actually does have an atmosphere there
is
air and the air uh will
tend to slow things down so one knows
perfectly well
if one if one will if one throws
something through the air
it will ex or one has a car going
through the air or an airplane going
through the air
there is air resistance what is that
well what's happening
is as the thing whatever it is the plane
or the thing you dropped whatever
is moving through the air it has to push
the air out of the way
in order to get through that particular
place and
so what has to happen is
that right at the surface of the object
there is
the the molecules of air are hitting the
object and they're bouncing off the
surface
and they're having to be and they'll
have to flow around the surface
so you can think about it at two levels
one is what happens to the molecules
the other is if you think about sort of
the air currents around the object
there has to be this kind of flow of air
around the object
it's very much the same thing happens in
water you can see if you
if you kind of run your hand through
some some
uh through water you can see that
there'll be this kind of
um uh there'll be this wake that's left
by your hand
um behind you behind your hand in the
water and that's kind of the
the you had to push water out of the way
in order to move your hand forward
and that as the water comes back behind
your hand that will make the structure
of this wake
okay so the question is how much
resistance to motion is there
associated with a fluid like water or
like air
and it turns out there are different
regimes of flow
so at low speeds there is what's called
laminar flow
and a higher speed speeds their
so-called turbulent flow so what is
laminar flow
so what's happening is as you move your
your
your finger through the water one
possibility is that the water is just
sort of separated by your finger
and it smoothly kind of slides around
your finger
and then comes back and recombines
behind your finger
laminar flow is this kind of smooth kind
of thing where
where you have these kind of layers
that's where the word lamina comes from
these layers of fluid around where your
finger is going
and that it's kind of a smooth sliding
through the fluid
okay so there's a fact about that which
is in laminar flow
the resistance to flow is proportional
to the speed of your finger
um so it's it's it's proportional to
velocity the
the formula is for the the the um
uh more or less more or less there's a
few detailed caveats to this
but more or less the resistance of
motion to motion
is proportional to the to the speed
okay so the faster you're going the more
that the the water is going to push back
and stop you going that fast
okay as things go faster what you'll see
is you
you look at you know behind your finger
you go sufficiently slowly the water
will sort of
slide around your finger and recombine
behind as you go a little bit faster
you'll start seeing little eddies
produced behind your finger
you'll start seeing little vortices
where the water is going around in a
circle
and you'll see behind your finger
there'll be eddies that break off first
from the top then from the bottom
around your finger there'll be this kind
of what's called a vortex street
of pairs of eddies that go off uh
in you know one the top one then the
bottom one top one etcetera
it makes this kind of street of eddies
behind your finger
and that happens as you go slightly
faster as you go even faster
what will happen is that street of
eddies will start becoming irregular the
eddies will no longer form this kind of
a nice kind of lamp post pattern or
something they'll instead have a more
complicated structure
and as you make your finger go even
faster the flow will no longer be
regular like that
it will start to be look much more
random and eventually it'll
it'll just look completely random but
there'll be this wake
and it'll be a so-called turbulent wake
where you have
sort of random motion of the fluid
behind you
so the mathematics of laminar flow is
reasonably well understood
it was understood 100 years ago the
mathematics of turbulent flow
is still not well understood there's
many aspects of it that are not
not known but some aspects are at least
empirically known
so for example in turbulent flow the
typical
uh the typical resistance to motion
is not like the velocity but it's like
the velocity squared
okay so so that's that's the when when
you drop something and there's turbulent
flow around the thing
then the resistance to motion will be
like the square of the velocity the
faster the thing is going
the uh the more resistance there'll be
and um
then it'll go up like the square of the
velocity
now it also matters in addition to what
the dependence on velocity is
there's also uh what the total amount of
force associated with
resistance to motion is and that depends
on the shape of the object
and so that's when the whole issue of
streamlining and so on comes in
so if you have an object and it's a
great big sail
you know it's going to be the amount of
force associated with
going through the air is going to be
much larger if it's a parachute for
example
the whole point of a parachute is to
have a very big
area that is um in set up so that
there's the maximum resistance to motion
so that the parachute slows you down as
much as possible
if you want something that's going to go
really fast you want something which is
streamlined
which is um has a you know an
aerodynamic shape
it has some kind of very pointy shape
that's kind of separating the air in the
best possible way
and not having a lot of resistance to
motion
so there's a thing called the drag
coefficient which characterizes
kind of the the result of whatever shape
you made
so things that have um like a sphere
will have a certain drag coefficient i
think it's around 0.15 usually for
for a typical typical um you know 10
miles an hour something type motion
um different kinds of shapes will have
different drag coefficients
and they can vary a lot depending on
whether it's a very pointy aerodynamic
shape
or a very parachute like sail-like shape
that just has lots of area and it's just
trying to
trying to kind of stop the air i should
also have said that
another thing that matters to their
resistance is what the
what the area that that uh the total
area of thing that the air is hitting
um and uh so in any case the
the bottom line on all of this is
there's all kinds of resistance to
motion
associated with having to move through
the air at low speeds it's this laminar
flow idea
at higher speeds it's turbulent flow at
lower speeds it's proportional just
linearly to the speed at higher speeds
as proportional the square of the speed
um so lots of resistance to motion
and um that resistance to motion
produces the following effect
so the acceleration due to gravity just
makes you go faster faster faster
but if you work out the kind of calculus
equations with this
resistance to motion in it it turns out
that what happens is
you eventually reach a so-called
terminal velocity
eventually the the gravity is trying to
make you go faster
but this air resistance is trying to
make you go slower and the result is
that you reach a constant velocity
and you don't go any faster than that
and depending on the shape of the object
the terminal velocity will be different
so for example a typical like
you know person falling through the air
the terminal velocity is around 100
miles
an hour um and that's so even though if
there wasn't any air
they would hit the ground at 25 000
miles an hour because there's air and
because they're the shape they are
you know roughly sort of a just a i
don't know
i don't know what shape we are just sort
of roughly a sphere in a first
approximation
um the uh uh the the result of that
is the the the sort of trade-off between
resistance of motion due to the air
acceleration due to gravity it ends up
with a terminal velocity of about 100
miles an hour
now different things will have
completely different terminal velocities
like
you drop a feather it has a completely
different terminal velocity
that um because it has high resistance
to motion
it um because of the shape and so on so
its terminal velocity will be
a tiny fraction of a mile per hour um so
the the question of the rate at which
things fall
depends on their shape it depends on
um it also depends on their mass
in in the air um and uh depends on their
size and so on so there can be
great variation i mean things that are
that are you know very aerodynamic
um things you know you have your average
you know missile or something
that's been intended to to fall rapidly
through the air
it will fall at a much higher speed and
so on it might be at
uh mark um you know maybe five times the
speed of sound or something like that
um which is uh um on the order of a few
thousand miles an hour
um as compared to uh sort of the the
falling person which might be 100 miles
an hour
so then i think our question had asked
what happens if you hit
water at that speed well
it's the same kind of story
how to think about this if you
if you just dive into water
oh i should explain you know when people
do diving and so on they try and make
themselves
as aerodynamic or hydrodynamic as
possible so they'll just sort of slice
their way into the water
rather than you know going splat on the
surface of the water
and this is the same phenomenon as
asking what is the
it's it's the same kind of idea as this
question of terminal velocity
in the air if you if you make yourself
more aerodynamic your terminal velocity
will increase
and so what's happening in the case of
the water
is in a sense you will be you will be
whenever you if you hit the water you
will be depending on your shape there
will be a certain essentially terminal
velocity in water
if that terminal velocity in water is
close to zero then you will be going
from whatever speed you were going at
and then you kind of go splat on the
surface of the water
and you're decelerating very rapidly and
that's bad news so to speak but if you
can make yourself very hydrodynamic
very kind of slicing into the water then
your terminal velocity in water will be
higher
and so the difference between whatever
speed you're going up which will be
probably the terminal velocity in
air and your terminal velocity in water
will be less great
and so you'll have less deceleration as
you go into the water
so you know in the in the the problem
for us humans is
that we don't do very well when we're
rapidly
accelerated or decelerated so for
example the
the acceleration due to gravity um 9.8
meters per second per
second we can ask the question if we
were to be
you know in a in a a plane that's you
know put its engines on full throttle
or a car that you know is is being
accelerated as quickly as possible you
know what is the acceleration
that is associated with that so for
example in a car you know you can go
zero to 60 miles an hour in some number
of seconds
and that will determine the acceleration
for the car and so
not sure i think uh what if you let's
imagine
that the car was accelerating at 9.8
meters per second per second
that means that the the uh
that there will be an effective it's as
if
there's a force of gravity that's
pulling you back into your
seat so to speak at the same sort of
with the same acceleration as the
earth's gravity is pulling you down
so effectively then it's as if the
direction of gravity
moved from being down towards the earth
to being more
back towards the the back of the car so
to speak
and so i don't know um i i think uh
what is the accelerations of um
i think um the fastest like with planes
and things like
small corporate planes and things i
think maybe you can get to two g's of
acceleration or something like that
from um just you know put the engines on
full throttle
and go from nothing to you know zipping
down the runway at
you know 100 miles an hour or something
um that um
uh and maybe race cars i don't know how
much how fast they um
they can accelerate another place where
you see acceleration
like that is if you're in a roller
coaster for example the roller coaster
is going
you know up to the top of a big sort of
roller coaster hill and then running
down to the bottom
and it runs down it's accelerating more
or less
at the acceleration due to gravity of
the earth and then
at the bottom you're you're being you're
you're being turned around so that
you're then going back up again
and there's acceleration associated with
the change of your speed
um and the change of the direction of
your motion
associated with that but the same is
true when you're so so a good way to
sort of simulate
um uh acceleration
is you just spin something around and
there will be acceleration because
you're changing
the direction of the velocity you're
changing the direction the thing is
going and that
in order to change that direction that
change of direction
corresponds to acceleration and so you
can have these centrifuges
where you're uh you know they're the
people in the
in the early days of the space program
there was a lot of testing
of what would it be like for people to
be at
uh at certain different accelerations
and they have these big centrifuges and
people would kind of sit in a little
capsule at the end of the centrifuge
they will the centrifuge around at
different rates
and that would give you different
effective accel different accelerations
um in that capsule so i think people do
um you can you know the question is what
happens at very high accelerations
to us humans and by five g's that's high
acceleration
five times acceleration due to gravity
that's high acceleration and all sorts
of terrible things happen i mean you
know
it's like you know the the blood drains
from one part of you into other parts of
you
this is an issue for people in military
planes
where the planes can do maneuvers that
have high acceleration
the um they you have to keep the pilot
from blacking out because all the
blood's gone from their brain
uh and uh and they can no longer get
oxygen to their brain and so on
and so there's a lot of sort of stuff to
do with having a pressure suit
that um that uh sort of forces
some uh blood to different parts of
of um of the body and things like this
and uh it tends to be the case that um
uh
well there's a lot of a lot of sort of
detail of that but um
uh you know one question is in the case
where
uh if you're sort of in a in some car
crash
um where you know the car is going at 60
miles an hour
and um uh you are about and you just
you know the thing rams into a brick
wall and
um you know how much acceleration is
there there the answer is
it can be 10 to 20 g's of acceleration
and that's really bad for us humans
the the way that things work like with
cars typically modern cars
have um uh there's this sort of crumple
zone at the front of the car where if
the thing's going to run into something
it will tend to be the case that the
front of the car
will kind of crumple which will reduce
the so in other words the the main part
of the car is going 60 miles an hour
um and if it was if it was just going
from 60 miles an hour to nothing
then that will be a very high
acceleration but because there's
a part of the front of the car that will
sort of gradually crumple not very
gradually it takes thousandths of a
second
um as as the thing crashes into
something
then that will make the acceleration of
the humans for example in the car be
less than it would otherwise have been
because it
it sort of more slowly comes to rest
than it would have done if it had just
gone
straight into the brick wall but things
bad things happen
all sorts of bad things happen to us i
think that the um uh
one of the really bad things is that the
um uh
some some uh
i think one of the typical things is
there are arteries connected to our
hearts
and they don't do very well in high
acceleration so that's one of the
one of the very bad things that happens
the good news about lots of modern cars
for example is that
they they have a hard time being crashed
straight into a brick wall because
they tend to have this kind of emergency
braking idea
which is usually based on on uh well i
guess
it's it's based on i guess nowadays
either radar or
um or visual cues
that the thing will will even if you
uh sort of uh you know it will tend to
automatically break
and prevent that from happening i think
the maximum rate when you
when you slam your foot on the brake of
a car i'm not sure what acceleration
that what the maximum acceleration is
i'm guessing a couple of g's
okay where g is is the acceleration due
to gravity on the surface of the earth
so okay long answer to your question
about uh what happens if you
if you fall from a great height um
let's see oh boy we've got some other
physics ones here
um
uh see there's a question from igor can
i explain the origin of the white
trails from jets at high altitude so
these are the so-called contrails
and um they what's happening is
that there is that it's kind of like
miniature clouds what is a cloud
a cloud is water vapor
that is almost condensing into liquid
water
if it were to fully condense into liquid
water it's like steam
that is almost condensing into liquid
water if it fully condensed into liquid
water
it would be rain and the rain would fall
from
out of the cloud but what's happening in
a typical cloud
is that you're you're getting sort of
the beginnings of condensation into
water
um but into liquid water but it isn't
quite there
in particular what happens is it's a
sort of a funny thing
so normally you think of water you've
got water you've got a big pile of
liquid water you heat it up
eventually it will boil and you'll get
steam
okay as you change the pressure of the
air
different things can happen so you can
the uh at different pressures you'll
it'll take
it'll be a different temperature at
which the water turns into steam
okay there is also a certain pressure at
which
you reach this um uh a little bit
complicated how all of this
is put together but you reach this thing
called the critical point
and at the critical point the the liquid
water
is so uh is so kind of rarefied it's not
very dense
and the vapor is quite dense
and in a sense you can't tell the
difference between the vapor
and the liquid water and the at that
critical point
one of the things that happens is you
essentially it's like
it's like the the the the water vapor
has little little droplets of water in
it
and that full water is like a big giant
droplet of water
but what happens at the critical point
is that there essentially a droplets at
all sizes
and it's it's typical of a phenomenon
in statistical physics to do with
critical phenomena but basically you
have
essentially it's like droplets of all
sizes and one of the consequences of
that
is that um the the reason
clouds are white is because they are
they have droplets of sort of all the
different sizes that will be necessary
to do things to light of all different
frequencies
light depending on the frequency it has
a characteristic
wavelength well this let this suffice it
to say that the way that
that clouds are white because they have
droplets of all sizes
and they um and that produces that
means that uh the light
of all of all frequencies whether it's
yellow or red or or blue whatever
is always um essentially reflected from
the cloud
and so so it ends up looking white but
um
what happens in um uh in contrails
is that as the plane goes through the
air it
disturbs the air and it produces
a um it it essentially is causing
essentially condensation it's cloud-like
condensation
i think at this critical point um to
form
behind the plane and what typically
happens is
the big place where that happens is the
wingtip vortices of the plane so what
happens is that
a plane um if you look at the the motion
of air around a plane
one of the big effects is that there's a
kind of swirling of air
at the at the at the end of the wings of
the plane
there are these vortices that form
behind the plane and those i think are
the places where the primary places
where these contrails form
is associated with the fact that the the
air
yes the air sort of wants to condense
into water
but it doesn't know where it should
start it doesn't know where the first
droplets should form
and when the plane comes through and
perturbs the air
it provides this kind of uh
it it gets it makes the air sufficiently
non-uniform that the air changes its
density a little bit
um and that's the place where that where
this condensation
starts to form and people uh
there are questions that i don't know
the answer to that have to do with
uh exactly what determines when
contrails will form and i think it's
very
random people are not very sure you know
a given plane
sometimes will make giant contrails and
sometimes it won't you might think
does it matter what the shape of the
wings is what does it matter to how the
contrails are formed
actually the wingtip vortices the the
general circulation of the air around a
plane
there's a certain amount of circulation
that is necessary for the plane to get
the lift
to stay flying so that is very much not
something you can really change by just
changing the shape of the wings
planes end up having these little
winglets at the end where the weather
where the wing is mostly flat but it
kind of goes up at the end
and you might think that would affect
these wingtip vortices i don't think it
does
um those are mostly to do with flow in
the
near the speed of sound those affect the
details of the flow
around the wings near the speed of sound
i don't think affect the the overall
circulation
we don't think affect the rate of
contrail formation
um
so there's a question here okay where
from brian if we rub mineral oil on us
will we move faster in water
ah yes an interesting question so there
was a big effort
for submarines um you know submarines
uh you want them to go faster can you
make can you do something that will make
a submarine
slide through the water more quickly i
think one thing that's
that has been done is if you boil the
water right right around the submarine
if you can make the water really hot
right around the submarine it will slide
much more easily through the water
than if the water is just in a sense
right at the surface of the submarine
kind of sticking to the submarine
there's a whole technology of trying to
coat things
in something that will make the water
kind of stick to the surface
much less so so what happens right at
the surface so at the surface of the
submarine
you've got the water that the submarine
is in and what's actually happening well
molecules are hitting the surface of the
submarine the sub the submarine is going
at a certain speed
the question is do you does
well put in a sort of physics terms does
some of the momentum of the submarine
get transferred to these water molecules
in other words
when a water molecule hits the submarine
does it end up bouncing back
in such a way that it is uh that
it it kind of knows that it hits
something in other words okay
if you hit if you've got a a ball and
you're you're
shooting it at something that's
completely stationary the ball
will uh will bounce back um
uh at the same angle that it hits the
thing
at so it'll it'll just bounce off uh
it'll hit at a certain angle it'll
bounce off at the same angle
if the thing that it hits is moving then
uh that may not be the case because some
of what may happen is
that the the that that uh
that some of the the motion of the thing
the ball hit
gets transferred to the ball and when
that happens
the result of that if you had it be lots
of the ball turned into lots of
molecules
the result of that is that some of the
the sort of forward motion
of the thing gets transferred to forward
motion of the
of the material around it of the water
let's say around it
and that means that it is essentially
there's there's more force needed
because not only are you trying to move
the submarine through the water
you're also trying to move this whole
layer of water
that is near the submarine that is
trying to be pulled at the same speed as
the submarine so
in effect you're trying to you're trying
to push through the water
not just the submarine but this much
bigger mass of water
that is trying to move at the same rate
of the submarine so if you could make
the submarine
be kind of just slide through the water
then
then it would work much better because
then you wouldn't have to move this big
mass of water
because it would just be there's the
submarine moving but it doesn't move
this mass
of water in a sense what you're doing is
to sort of lubricate
the the motion of the submarine so so
when you have
if you have something like um you have
two solid surfaces
and they're kind of grinding against
each other and one is sort of trying to
move the other one
or what one is no one is let's say let's
say you have something
and it's a it's a it's some kind of axle
and it's got some kind of casing around
the axle
the axle is turning around but it's got
a casing around it that's keeping the
axle in place
but the casing around it is producing
friction that's trying to stop the axle
from moving around
in a sense what the axle wants to do is
to try and turn its casing around with
it
but if you keep the casing fixed
there'll just be friction between the
axle and the casing
how do you make that friction less well
you put a lubricant like oil
in and what that lubricant is doing is
it's kind of making it be the case that
it no longer
has to be true that the that this solid
object there
is is is sort of is directly touching
this casing
instead it's got this layer of liquid in
between and one side of the liquid the
side of the liquid that's right close to
the axle that's turning around
will turn around along with the axle but
then the
the then there's a uh the the liquid
there isn't the liquid that's close to
the casing
will be stationary and depending on the
characteristics of the liquid
you can make it be the case that the the
uh
the thing will just make allow things to
sort of slide more easily
and you can do the same thing with you
know submarine moving through water it's
the same idea except that instead of
trying to prevent sort of friction
between two solid objects
you're preventing friction between one
solid object and one liquid
and so many experiments have been done
on many kinds of molecules that you
could
coat submarines in and so on that would
make the um
the the resistance be smaller and people
sometimes claim
remarkable results about that uh that
depend on particular properties of
molecules and
i don't know all the details of that and
many of those details
are probably secret because people don't
want people to know
uh you know just how fast military
submarines move and so on
okay let's see uh
boy more more of these um
um there's a question here from wardrobe
how long will we survive if the earth
left the sun's orbit
going away from the sun that's a good
question
so uh
the good news is it's tough to see how
that would happen
i mean it could happen if if an asteroid
collided with the earth it might
throw the earth off you know out of its
orbit
and it might start sort of careening
away from the sun but okay so what would
happen if the earth
for some reason moved its orbit further
away from the sun
obviously we would stop getting solar
radiation we'd stop getting the heat and
light from the sun
and the earth would gradually cool down
and the question is one question would
be at what rate would the earth cool
down
so one thing that's worth knowing is the
center of the earth has still not cooled
down
in 4.6 billion years since the earth was
formed
the center of the earth still has heat
that is left over from when the earth
was formed
and in fact one of the things that's
surprising so the basic story would be
if you want to stay warm go underground
and um
one of the things that's sort of
surprising is if you look between summer
and winter and things like that
the air is changing temperature a lot in
most places between summer and winter
but if you dig down in the soil if you
dig down in the ground
you don't have to go very deep before
the
there is really no change in temperature
throughout the year
and there's a certain average
temperature i think it's about 50
degrees fahrenheit typically in
in like um in many places on the earth
that is if you dig down not quite sure
how far it is it's only a few feet
you you dig down that distance in for
example soil
it is the case that the rate at which
heat
is transmitted through the soil is slow
enough
that throughout the course of a whole
year there's almost no temperature
variation
in um uh in the temperature of the of
the soil at that depth
and as i say that's a sufficiently
extreme effect
that when it comes to temperature sort
of escaping from the center of the earth
um it in in billions of years that
hasn't happened
i mean there are other sources of heat
in the earth about half the heat in the
center of the earth
the center of the earth is molten um
below the the crust
that's maybe 50 miles ish
down around the the um the on the
surface of the earth
if you go down below that you get to the
mantle of the earth and the mantle of
the earth is liquid
it also has a core in the middle that's
probably solid um
but um most of the earth's interior is
liquid
and that the heat that keeps that liquid
some fraction maybe half of it is left
over from when the earth was formed
4.6 billion years ago and half of it is
due to the decay of radioactive elements
that released energy and release heat um
but that gives you a sense of the fact
you can stay
pretty warm by just digging down and
using rock
to uh to keep you insulated so to speak
so i kind of think
that um uh the um
you know you can um you can do that
if it's a question of you know do you
get to use you know how do you get
energy well you can you can do the same
uh you know solar energy is
is uh uh less and less of a thing as we
get further and further away from the
sun
it's worth realizing even on the surface
of the earth it's a big deal what
latitude you're at
if you're close to the north pole then
there will be times of year where well
the times of year when it's just dark
uh half the year it's dark above the
arctic circle and so clearly
if you want solar energy during that
period of time you're out of luck
but for example it's a it's a
calculation when people have
oh for example high altitude drones that
are going to
get their power from uh
from from um photovoltaics from
from um solar cells effectively the um
uh it really matters what latitude
they're flying at how
how far up north they are because the
effective
um uh the effective amount of solar
radiation
depends on the angle at which the the
sun at which your kind of um
uh the the angle of the surface of the
earth relative to the sun
and so typically many of those systems
it'll be like it only works
up to the northernmost part of the u.s
it won't work in canada
because there just isn't enough solar
radiation at that angle and so on or
it'll work much better in the caribbean
than it does in uh you know in minnesota
or something
so let's see i for some reason i'm i'm
uh
i'm reminded there's a uh uh
a chinese science fiction movie that
came out fairly recently
that's about exactly this point of if
the um um
if the earth moved um away from the the
sun
what happens and i think that's a story
of uh then you live underground for lot
for a long period of time
um how well that really works for us
humans i don't know but that's a
different
different kind of question all right
let's see uh
let's see there's a question here from
k about could everything that gets
sucked into all the black holes
everywhere in the universe
go to the same place
okay the bad news is it doesn't go
anywhere
because a black hole so black hole is
this
is this region of space where
there is which has an event horizon
around it which means
things can go into it but can't get out
from it
well the the type of inventorizing the
black holes have
has that characteristic there are other
event horizons where things can't go in
either direction
but with a black hole event horizon
things can go in but can't come out
and the reason that that happens is
there's sufficiently much gravity
associated with this black hole that the
escape velocity
is larger than the speed of light so
even if you were
a photon going at the speed of light you
can't go
fast enough to escape the gravity
associated with this black hole
well so what happens
in uh in one of these black holes
black holes arise from in practice
the the ones we we have observed come
from the collapse of massive stars
that eventually no longer can get
uh sort of kept at sort of star size by
all this heat that's being produced by
nuclear reactions in the star
they collapse and they collapse down to
the point where they're sort of crushed
by the gravity of the object and they
get crushed into this very tiny
region that maybe a kilometer across or
something but has all the mass of the
star in it
and that that is sufficiently much uh
there's sufficiently
high gravity gravity there that you have
this phenomenon
of forming an event horizon having it be
the case that the escape velocity is
larger than the speed of light
so the question is what happens inside
that region
that is uh that that where nothing can
kind of get out
and the answer is the mathematics of
what happens
in such a region the mathematics of what
can happen in einstein's equations for
gravity and for the structure of
space-time is that's
comparatively easy to work out in the at
what
are some possible things that could
happen that have an event horizon
and have the equivalent of mass inside
what actually happens with a collapsed
star inside can be more complicated
but what happens in the kind of theory
of these things
is you form a singularity in space-time
so
normally uh normally what happens is
oh boy this is getting i'm backing into
some kind of complicated things
so roughly what happens okay so
so think about how do we how do we
understand the structure of space
one way we can do it is we say we shoot
a laser in some direction
we just say we're going to assume the
laser always goes in a straight line
if we are just you know you shoot a
laser across your backyard or something
you'll just see that this
this uh this light will just go in a
straight line
okay so the big idea of the standard
theory of gravity
general relativity is that actually the
laser the beam won't always go in a
straight line and doesn't always go in a
straight line
because the structure of space is curved
so for example uh the the the one of the
rules will be
that the light always goes on the
shortest path it can given two points
it's going from here to there
the light will always take the path that
is shortest to get from one point to
another
what is the shortest path well the
shortest path depends on
what space you're in so for example on
the surface of the earth
the shortest path between two points is
this great circle path
that is on the surface of the earth it's
if you looked at it from outside the
earth you would see that the path is
curved
because it's it's it's following the
surface of the earth
and if you imagine that you're on on a
surface
and the surface has a certain shape you
can see that the shortest path between
two points
when you're keeping on that surface
won't be something that is a straight
line when viewed from the outside
and so the the basic point in in
einstein's theory of gravity
is that which our new theory of
fundamental
physics nicely reproduces um the the
basic point there
is that when there is a mass when
there's
mass in the universe it causes the
structure of space to be deformed it
causes curvature in space
and that curvature in space will deflect
the paths
of the deflect these shortest paths and
so what happens is
when you have a massive object the space
is curved
the shortest path is no longer a
straight line it's instead something
that's deflected towards the mass
and it's deflected in just the way that
corresponds to the deflection due to
gravity
of that particular thing so the basic
point is when there is mass
so-called gd6 shortest paths are
are attracted towards the mass it's
basically the same thing as i was
talking about earlier in in terms of
things fall towards massive objects
gravity
gravity pulls things in you see that in
the convergence of these jd6
well what happens is
inside one of the sort of defining
characteristics of black holes
is they produce this convergence of
parts so in other words all these things
even though they're coming from all
these different angles and
moving in all these different ways
they'll all converge to a point
and one of the things that i was sort of
i was going to explain what the
singularity in space time
is about oh boy let me see how to best
talk about that
um essentially what happens at the
singularity is that the curvature of
space becomes infinite
and so you can measure the curvature of
space
by asking for example uh
if you were to have an object there
how would the the
if you look at these gd6 these paths you
can ask questions about
how much deformation in that path will
there be
in a sense at the center of a black hole
there's infinite deformation in the path
so what that actually happens is uh and
again it's a little complicated but what
basically happens is
that the end result is that time
stops so these these pods are going
along they're going along they're
converging they're converging
eventually they get to the point where
they've completely converged
and the paths have no place to go and so
in that sense these paths are they're
sort of
progressing with time but at some point
they've converged the point where
there's no
they don't move through time they are
just stuck
time stops and so the way that that will
if you were just sort of
falling into that point then
you know you're thinking oh time is
passing time is passing
time is passing more slowly and then you
get to that center point and you can no
longer
you are completely stuck it's like if
like if you were a computer
that was running the computer's clock
would stop the computer would just there
would be no further instructions
executed
the computer wouldn't know that anything
had happened to it because it wouldn't
know anything it's just stuck it's just
stopped
and so what happens is that at the
center of a black hole
well at least the simplest kind of black
hole time just stops
all of these different parts of what
happens to to anything that's sort of
falling into the black hole
they it they just get to the point where
where nothing further will happen with
them because time is effectively stopped
now that's true with with uh the
simplest kind of black holes so-called
schwarzschild black holes
which are non-rotating black holes there
are other black holes that are rotating
so-called curb black holes and the
situation with them is considerably more
complicated
and they have a different kind that the
thing i've just described
is called the space-like singularity um
it's a place where
basically time ends um there is
what can happen in other cases is there
places where space
ends where all of space is crushed into
a single
there's there's just this sort of single
point in space
and time progresses but nothing can
there's no possibility of any extension
in space
um so now the question would be if
uh so when time ends
if you ask the question does everything
that kind of goes into the sinkhole of a
black hole
does it all end up in the same place
does it all go to the
the giant sewer of the universe or
something the answer is
well not in a schwarzschild black hole
because time just stops
it doesn't go anywhere it's just like
it's it's frozen
okay in the case of a curl black hole
these rotating black holes
it's a more complicated story and
let me think about that for a second um
yes okay
so in the traditional theory of gravity
every black hole that forms is its own
thing there's no connection between any
any two of them
they and so that means that whatever is
whatever is formed there there's no
possibility
of some kind of weird wormhole in the
structure of space
time that connects this black hole to
this other black hole over here
that simply can't form in the way that i
mean in in formal terms they're these uh
uh hawking penrose singularity theorems
that tell you things about how
singularities are inevitably form in the
structure of space-time
when there are these massive objects
that collapse and
in the structure of those theorems i
think it is
it has to be the case that every black
hole is its own island so to speak
that there's no possibility of a of a
connection between these different black
holes
that's true for the traditional theory
of gravity um
in in our theory of the structure of
space
which kind of goes into more detail and
kind of tells you what's
what sort of what space is made of
rather than just telling you
kind of the characteristics of space as
we observe it
in in our models it is more possible to
have connections between different
in the usual model the main issue is
that
you can't change the topology of space
so topology is something like
you have a sphere it's got no holes in
it you've got a doughnut it's got a big
hole in the middle
you can't continuously deform a sphere
to make it into a doughnut there's
there's some moment at which the whole
first forms and that's sort of a
discontinuous thing that's happening
and in the universe you can't kind of go
from being something that sort of
doesn't have a hole in it to something
that does
in the standard theory of gravity that's
just impossible just can't happen
in um in our theory that actually can
happen um at least at very small scales
and so it's more possible that you could
conceivably have a connection
between two black holes it will not be a
natural thing to form because most black
holes
are just forming as a result of a star
collapsing and so that won't happen
there can be a slightly bizarre
phenomenon which is a connection between
a black hole and a white hole
and that's uh that's that will get us
into a whole whole another can of worms
white holes presumably can't actually
exist in our universe
uh presumably they're they're infinitely
unstable
and any time a white hole which is kind
of a thing which spews everything out
anytime that's that's happening um that
uh uh there will be an instability which
will cause it to
to no longer do that and sort of break
into a bunch of black holes and so on
the one exception to that is in a sense
the beginning of our universe the big
bang at the beginning of our universe
is a little bit like a white hole um but
it's uh
but in in general things it goes the
other way that things always sort of
converge
that mass always makes things converge
well let's see maybe one or two more um
questions oh there's a question from
stenio
do black holes rotate can they distort
the space time around them
yeah well so any massive object is
distorting space time around it
and that's because the the presence of a
gravitational field
is in einstein's theory of gravity
equivalent to a distortion of space-time
black holes can rotate typically a black
hole
you might say you look at a star a star
has all kinds of protuberances and you
know it's sending out all these giant
jets into space and so on
a black hole the actual part of it it's
associated with its
event horizon is very perfect it's a
very
kind of smooth event horizon there can
be all kinds of things that happen
outside the event horizon but the actual
event horizon something very smooth
and the only characteristics that one
can typically tell
from sort of the gravity outside of the
event horizon or the total mass of the
black hole
and the angular momentum the rate at
which the black hole is rotating
you can also tell things like electric
charge and so on but
um so yes there are rotating black holes
in fact most black holes rotate
um the thing that is interesting about
black hole rotation
is there's a limit to the rate of
rotation given a particular mass of
black hole
there's an upper limit to the rate at
which the black hole can rotate
while not changing the structure of
space time a great deal around the black
hole
one of the things that happens is a
phenomenon called frame dragging
which is as when when you're around
when you're close to the black hole the
um uh
oh let's see it's as if light
that gets close to the black hole is
kind of dragged around with a black hole
it's a little bit like it's almost as if
there's sort of a a um it's almost as if
there's a the light
near the black hole is um is made
to be um uh it's it's almost like a
friction between
between what's happening and the
rotation of the black hole and it causes
it causes the um uh uh
well it causes the direction of light to
be turned so that it is
so that it tends to be dragged along
with the rotation of the black hole
okay that's all well and good until you
reach
the critical angular momentum the
critical
um uh spin of the black hole at which
point
what happens is offices gets very weird
the event horizon so normally in a black
hole there's this event horizon things
can go into the event horizon
they cannot escape from the event
horizon at the center of the black hole
there is the singularity in spacetime
this place where the curvature of space
goes to infinity this place where for
example time
stops or space stops or some other
pathology happens
but that that place where time stops for
example
is forever hidden from the outside world
by the presence of the event horizon
so if you're like if you're going to say
i want to do this
this tv special about what happens at
the center of the black hole
you'll never succeed because once you've
fallen in through the event horizon of
the black hole
you can never send a signal back out to
tell the world
what you see at the center of a black
hole that's not true for black holes
that rotate
sufficiently fast if any momentum in
some units is bigger than the mass
if they're spinning too rapidly then it
would be the case
that there isn't an event horizon at
least it has a very different structure
you can actually the the naked there's a
naked singularity a place where
there's actually the singularity at the
center of the black hole
can actually sort of communicate out to
the outside world
people believed for a long time that
black holes could never form where there
were naked singularities
and that it was always the case
that somehow when you have actual matter
that that somehow it would always be
somehow unstable
and somehow that the black hole would
eject material
and no longer be going at the same
angular momentum and so on
and that it somehow wouldn't ever be
able to achieve that critical angle
momentum
it turns out when you look at black
holes that we actually observe
that there are a bunch of black holes
that are very close to the criticalizing
momentum
but none that we've observed that have
larger angle momentum so it does seem to
be the case that there's this upper
limit on the
on the rate of spinning of a black hole
that is produced by some kind of
instability but people have believed
that there was simply no way to get a
naked singularity no way to construct it
then it was found i don't know maybe 10
years ago or so now
that by a very elaborate way of
imagining sort of adding matter in in
just
this in just the right way you can
actually sort of navigate things to the
point where you have a very weak
but nevertheless non-zero singularity
that is in principle
accessible to the outside world and
actually we were
about to start looking at how this works
in the context of our models because i
think it's going to be a lot clearer
there
exactly what's needed my guess is that
the the sort of what you need to be able
to maintain a singularity
while not filming an event horizon
around it is something that is a very
complicated sort of put up job it's the
same kind of thing if you have
molecules of gas in a room if you could
have this sort of microscopic device
that every time it sees a molecule going
this way it bats it off to go in a
different direction
and so on if you had that microscopic
device eventually
you could push all the gas into the room
to one side
and leave a vacuum on the other side but
that's extremely hard to do because
you'd have to have this little
microscopic thing
that's looking at every single gas
molecule and figuring out exactly what
to do
my guess is it's the same kind of thing
that's needed to achieve this kind of
arrangement of matter that will produce
a naked singularity
uh that that is not does not have an
event horizon around it
all right i should wrap up in just a
moment here let's see if there's
anything that i think i can do
um in
[Music]
oh i'll try one more um
uh
boy there's several interesting ones
here many interesting ones here okay
there's one from goodlands here
what is the reason for the distribution
of matter and antimatter throughout the
universe
why is there less antimatter okay
so first point is
mata protons electrons those kinds of
things
one of the things that's a very
fundamental piece of the quantum theory
of
quantum field theory uh sort of
fundamental piece of particle physics
is to every particle there's a
corresponding anti-particle sometimes
the anti-particle is the same as the
particles
itself like it is for a photon but
usually like with an electron
it has negative charge there's also a
positron with positive charge
there's the anti-particle of the
electron proton there are anti-protons
and so on and so for every particle
there is an anti-version of it
and those anti-versions things like
their electric charge is the negative of
the particle itself
the only thing that doesn't get negated
is its mass
its mass is still positive that's an
interesting thing that actually in our
fundamental theory of physics we
actually understand why it happens that
way
it's been much less clear why that
happens but um
we sort of understand why that happens
but so antimatter
positive mass negative charge when
matter and antimatter meet
they tend to annihilate each other so
for example an electron and a positron
if they meet up
they will eventually annihilate and turn
into two or three photons
um and uh they will the the
the the energy that's associated with
their mass will turn into in that case
the
the the the photons have zero mass so it
turns into sort of
pure energy of the photons okay
so one of the things when i was younger
we didn't know
is whether a next-door galaxy in our
universe was made of antimatter
it could have been the case it would
seem very nice and symmetrical
if like okay our galaxy is made of mata
but
the next door galaxy might be made of
antimatter and there might be a random
distribution of matter and antimatter
galaxies around the universe well
we probably know that that's not the
case we have increasing evidence that's
not the case
because essentially if there was matter
in one galaxy an antimatter in the other
galaxy
there will be a small trace of you know
for example if two galaxies happen to
to collide giant explosion as the mata
and antimatter in the
in the galaxy and the anti-galaxy
annihilated each other and we don't see
things like that
so we kind of think that all the
galaxies in the universe are made of
matter
so that raises the question how come if
that's the case
that means there's lots more matter in
the universe than antimatter
how could that be why would the universe
be asymmetric in that sense
well i actually worked on this problem
about 40 years ago now
and we don't completely know the answer
there is at least hypothesis
but it isn't a very good hypothesis yet
um
it it matters to the hypothesis that
uh well okay so so roughly what happens
okay in the sufficiently early universe
if you have
if things are sufficiently hot if
there's sufficiently much energy being
sort of pumped around
you make uh matter antimatter
you make particle antiparticle pairs if
you just put energy in just like when
when electron and positron meet they
turn into sort of pure energy of photons
similarly if the photons have enough
energy and you just sort of collide
photons together
they'll make an electron positron pair
and so in the early universe
when the universe was very young and
very hot um
the the the pure energy associated with
that heat
would have produced particle
antiparticle pairs actually
in the sufficiently early universe it
would produce
uh an anti-particle antiparticle pairs
for all possible kinds of particles
however massive they are so they'll be
top quark anti-tox pairs
they'd be proton antiproton pairs all
sorts of things more like cork antique
work pairs
but um there'd be all these different
kinds of particle anti-particle pairs
so just generating particles and
antiparticles from pure heat so to speak
you get an equal number of particles and
antiparticles so how do you end up with
more
particles than antiparticles more matter
than antimatter
tricky business okay so
the theory is ah this is complicated
okay so the theory relies on certain
things that aren't have not been seen
so it is believed that protons protons
seem to be stable
protons are made from quarks and so on
it seems like protons never decay
but there's pretty some decent reason to
believe
that if you were to wait sufficiently
long we know it's more than 10 to the 31
years
then you would see protons tending to
decay if you were the
lifetime of proton you know will decay
at some very very very very slow rate
and a proton will decay into a positron
and photons neutrinos things like that
that violates a bunch of sort of
conservation laws that we think are true
in physics
but at some very very slow rate those
will get violated
we think never been observed so we don't
know that for sure
in the sufficiently early universe that
phenomenon would
lead to in this kind of when there's
when you make things hot enough you put
enough energy in
that phenomenon will happen much more
often than
oh actually no that's not the main point
the main point is
uh right there that phenomenon is
associated with
particles that have very short lifetimes
but which are doing things that
that will produce that will be like it
can sort of produce a proton from
nothing so to speak
but it happens it's a particle that has
very high mass very short lifetime
can be produced in the very early
universe but wouldn't ever be produced
subsequently
except in some kind of virtual way as a
result of
of um as part of the proton decay
process
um the uh
so in any case the thing that um
uh happens okay in the sufficiently
early universe
this phenomenon um these these particles
that we've never observed
might be produced we've never even
observed their effects
uh for those who are paying attention to
these things the particles were believed
to maybe have
a mass of about 10 to 15 times the mass
of the proton
um and at least when i was working on
these things that's 40 years ago and so
it might have changed since
we used to call these particles with the
with the very convenient letter capital
x
but i don't know whether they're i don't
know that they've been renamed since
then
but any case these particles which we
don't know exist
they would be produced in the very early
universe and
the tricky thing is that
okay this this requires one more step
and then then we'll um
okay um
when particles and antiparticles have
the feature
that their mass is always the same their
lifetime is also the same
if you have a decaying let's say you
have i don't know a neutron which
happens to when it's
isolated on its own it decays at a
certain rate
an anti-neutron decays at the same total
rate
and that is a consequence of a thing
called cpt invariance which is a very
fundamental consequence of the of the
mathematical structure of quantum field
theory
um it turns out that the one
thing that can be different is when a
particle can decay
in many different ways so it could decay
into this or it could decay into that
the the so-called partial rates
of different decays can be different
between particles and anti-particles
that is the total lifetime the total
rate of the particle decaying is always
the same
but the partial rates can be different
and the partial rates are not forced to
be the same by this fundamental feature
of the mathematical structure of quantum
field theory and so the belief is
that these weird particles these x
particles in the very early universe
had different decay rates to what now
count as as matter and what now count as
antimatter
and as a result of that the um those
those things will have produced those
those particles will be produced in the
very early universe
their decay will be preferentially to a
little bit more preferentially to mata
than to antimatter
only by about one part and ten to the
one part in a billion
because that's actually the the roughly
in the universe we know
that if you just look at sort of all
stuff in the universe it's mostly
photons and things like that
and there's only a small fraction of it
that isn't things like quarks and
electrons and so on
it's about a billionth of the universe
isn't just photons a billionth of the
universe
has this asymmetry between matter and
antimatter so that small asymmetry
is associated we think with the
difference
in the in the in the rates of these
these particles produced in the early
universe decaying into one thing as
compared to the other
and the interaction of that with things
to do with expansion of the universe
produces this long-term effect of this
just a little bit more matter than
antimatter
and as the universe kind of cooled down
lots of matter antimatter annihilation
would have happened
but there'd be a little residue one part
in a billion left over that is mata and
not antimatter
and that's supposedly where we all come
from this is not a completely
satisfactory theory
um there are aspects of this where we
just don't know that that's
whether that's really the way it works
and there are phenomena in there
that have never been observed and that
we think should be observable at some
point
if this theory is right but that's the
that's the main prevailing theory
for why there's more matter than
antimatter in the universe um
and uh uh that's um
uh it's it's a sort of a it's almost a
footnote type theory it's a
it's a weird little minor mismatch
between the rates of decay into this
thing versus that thing
and that leads to everything we know
which is sort of a curious feature of
often the way that physics works it's
everything we care about is in a
footnote so to speak
and um this is one of those cases all
right i should wrap up
for now here and um
lots of interesting questions which we
can continue on
next week and i think next week is a
holiday in the u.s but we plan to do
this
anyway on that um on that day
so um uh thanks for joining us i think i
have to go do
some uh work for my day job and actually
there'll be another
live stream about completely different
kinds of things with software design
in uh just a few minutes here so
thanks for joining me